[Musique]
quand on porte l'uniforme les départs au
petit matin c'est une question d'habitude
la ville s'éveille la base aérienne 125 Distre
ne s'est jamais assoupi les départs en mission
c'est le quotidien du militaire on va dire que
c'est plutôt fréquent par concernant là je suis
parti au Liban l'année dernière donc de juin
jusqu'à au mois de novembre et là je repars
du coup cette année donc une petite année
de de ri chez moi et je repars quels sont
les les sentiments d'un militaire la proche
d'embarquer dans l'avion les premières fois
c'est un peu stressant mais là c'est mon trè
départ donc Mo moins d'appréhension un peu plus
serein on attend toujours d'être dans l'avion
pour être s de bien partir on sait jamais mais
oui c'est on commence en l'habitude avec un
peu un peu d'expérience ok on est bon pour la
musette c'est tout bon pour moi je vous laisse
avancer tout droit s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup
il y a beaucoup de personnes là ils partent
pour où c'est tous ces gens ils sont 205 et
ils partent pour la Roumanie c'est un volume
c'est un volume important oui c'est un gros
volume mais après c'est relativement habituel
pour nous est-ce que l'activité s'est densifié
ces derniers temps oui tout à fait depuis
que Cray est descendu chez nous ça c'est
relativement inensifié puis avec les événements
qui se passent dans le monde on a pas mal de
[Musique]
travail en H colonnes [Musique] Vicu si
l'activité s'est densifiée c'est que la base
est devenue une plateforme majeure de l'Armée
de l'Air et de l'Espace depuis plusieurs mois
elle est le principal point de part de tous
les militaires en [Musique] opération Istre
est la plus grande base aérienne de France on
raconte qu'elle était capable d'accueillir la
navette spatiale américaine grâce à sa piste
de 5 km mais depuis plus d'un an la BA 125
comme l'appellent les aviateurs vit au rythme
d'un chantier colossal bonjour ça va bonjour la
première difficulté dès le départ c'était d'être
en mesure de faire transiter autant de passagers
sur une base qui par essence ne peut pas laisser
passer n'importe qui du coup il a fallu imaginer
ce terminal à cheval sur la limite de la base pour
être en mesure de faire entrer les personnes de
pouvoir assurer leur filtrage et ensuite de
pouvoir les mener vers l'espace où ils vont
mener les procédures d'embarquement d'accord et
d'enregistrement donc là si si vous voulez on va
faire le finalement le cheminement que feront les
passagers lorsquil viendront embarquer dans ces
murs le service d'infrastructure de la défense a
conçu un nouveau terminal passager un projet qui
transforme la base aérienne en un véritable roiss
militaire l'objet principal de ce terminal c'est
d'être en mesure de de projeter plus de 100000
passagers par an et de pouvoir affrter simultan
deux appareils de projection long courrier donc
plus de 540 passagers simultanément la fonction
c'est également de pouvoir projeter tout types
de matériel pour cela on va énormément augmenter
notre capacité à traiter du frit par voie
aérienne puisque nous allons passer d'environ
2000 tonnes par an jusqu'en 2020 à plus de
9000 tonnes à échéance 2024 et dans un 3è
temps nous devrons être en mesure de pouvoir
projeter tout type de munition et d'explosion
et pour cela nous allons faire construire
à l'écart de toute habitation et de tout
bureau une zone qu'on appelle Hute cargo dans
laquelle nous allons pouvoir conditionner tout
type de de munition et encore une fois et
d'explosifs pour pouvoir les transporter
par voie [Musique] aérienne donc comme je vous le
disais ici c'est la salle d'enregistrement donc ce
sera la salle d'attente quand les gens arriveront
peut-être un petit peu en avance avant de prendre
leur avion pour vous c'est une très grosse
plusvalue opérationnelle pour la projection
des forces alors c'est très grosse plusvalue parce
que on gagne énormément d'autonomie tout reposera
uniquement sur du personnel militair avec des
contrôleurs aériens militaires du personnel au
sol militaire et tout sera internalisé et puis
évidemment on gagne sur le long terme d'un point
de vue financier puisque le être hébergé à roissie
Charles de Gaulle ça coûtait aux armées environ 15
millions par an donc en l'espace d'à peine 3
ans je dirais on rentabilise l'investissement
d'infrastructure le carousel est
pas installé encore non bah on
peut peut-être aller directement au voir lesag les
tribagages finalement dans l'infrastructure on
n'a pas l'habitude de faire du tribagage des
convoyeurs des machines à rayon X c'est quelque
chose de de vraiment nouveau donc ici déjà on
a eu des contraintes techniques parce qu'on a la
charpente globale du bâtiment il a fallu également
mettre une nouvelle charpente pour intégrer tout
le système tribagage et donc et là on est vraiment
sur les normes civiles internationales pour
permettre à un avion MRTT de pouvoir atterrir
dans n'importe quel aéroport et de pouvoir
surtout livrer les bagages dans n'importe quel
aéroport on est quand même fier du résultat et
on espère enfin on espère avoir un très bon rendu
prochainement la mise en service de ce
terminal est la dernière pièce d'un programme
d'infrastructure destiné à renforcer la capacité
d'intervention et de projection de l'armée franç
à l'international l'escale de la BA 125
est entièrement dédié à cette mission
365 jours par [Musique] an aujourd'hui nous
travaillons sur un terminal aéroportuaire qui
a été construit dans les années 90 et pour
pouvoir embarquer du fret et des passagers
sur des procédures des années 90 sans forcément
appliquer les normes Schengen qui n'étaient pas
appliqué au militaire à cette époque-là le
nouveau terminal aéroport puaire lui répond
à toutes les normes actuelles pour pouvoir
embarquer dans des conditions réglementaires
et dans les meilleures conditions d'accueil non
militaires demain l'ensemble des projections
seront effectué au départ de la base aérienne
et donc c'est bien tout ce volume qui avant
était réparti sur plusieurs bases en
France qui sera centralisé sur la base a
indistre pour développer ces nouvelles
infrastructures la base aérienne
s'appuie sur les liens historiques qu'elle
entretient avec sa ville les besoins de
l'armée et la technologie qui est prononcé
aujourd'hui trouve domicile ici et ça montre
que notre base je dirais est un élément stratégie
d'un défense nationale qu'elle prend place encore
plus dans l'organisation militaire de l'OTAN et
et d'autres éléments qui sont décisifs pour les
théâtres guerriers et donc nous effectivement
nous sommes associés heureux de l'être
depuis une dizaine d'années la modernisation
du parc aéronautique de l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace a accéléré la montée en puissance de la
be avec 15 appils groste la5 ABR désormais la plus
important flotte militaire de ce type en Europe
les a de la base c'est lui les aviateurs baptis
du nom d'un oiseau légendaire le phix SAF que cet
oiseau fait 60 m de long et presque 20 m de haut
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements] [Musique]
[Applaudissements]
our parfait et c'est bon pour vous c'est tout
bon alors si on parle que des capacités de
ravitaillement ça tout changer en fait parce
qu'on a une capacité d'emport de carburant qui
est largement supérieure à celle qu'on avait
sur Boeing avant le Boeing à titre d'exemple
on pouvait emmener dans les 85 90 tonnes de
carburant mais il fallait des conditions bien
spécifiques pour les emmener on il fallait
que la température soit basse que toutes les
conditions soient réunies pour pouvoir emmener ce
carburant avec cet avion on en mène pas beaucoup
plus finalement on en mène 109 tonnes mais on
peut les emmener quoi qu'il arrive quelle que
soit la température quel que soit longueur de
piste à pe de chose près ça va fonctionner la
grosse différence également c'est que le on a
apporté une capacité de transport qu'on avait
pas du tout en tout cas pas à cette échelle sur
le Boeing on se retrouve à pouvoir transporter
du passager du FR fairevacuation sanitair en
même temps qu'on fait du ravitaement en vol donc
est capable de faire toutes les missions et de
toutes les faire en même temps ce qui est le gros
changement qu' apporté cet appareil CP à 9h 8h30
à 895 on a besoin de 5 4 ça n fait 5 t 5 d'extra
ouais je sais ce que j' quelle quantité de de
carburant tu délivres et en combien de temps
euh alors ça va dépendre de de l'aéronef qu'on
a en général pour les rafales on est quand même
sur un plus gros débit on est aux alentours de
1 tonne par minute c'est pas une masse à faire
parce que le panier il est tout petit et le le
moindre petit écart la moindre petite turbulence
peut faire que le panier euh part dans tous
les sens et là ça devient dangereux d'où ma
place aussi dans l'arvitaement c'est de garder
l'intégrité et des chasseurs et de notre [Musique]
avion il y a quelques mois le Phénix a participé
à l'une des plus importantes démonstrations de
force de l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace objectif
être capable d'intervenir en quelques heures à
autre bout du monde alors Pegas c'était une une
véritable opération puisque nous avons 5 MRTT
10 rafales et 4 à 400 m qui sont partis de la
basirien Distre dans la nuit du 24 au 25 juin
2023 en fait le le but de cette de cette manœuvre
était de déployer dans des délais contraints des
forces dans la zone Indo-Pacifique le dispositif
s'est scindé en deux boucles une boucle qui est
allée d'abord à Singapour puis sur l'île de GAM
et l'autre boucle qui est allé en Malaisie avant
finalement de revenir en métropole via les Émirats
arabes unis finalement le MRTT est un avion qui
est encore assez euh qui est qui est récent et
donc l'intégration à des coalitions la mise en
place de procédures communes était également
un des objectifs de de pégaz pour arriver en
zone Indo-Pacifique il a fallu moins de 40
he donc on montre que finalement dès qu'il
va se passer quoi que ce soit dans dans cette
zone où la France a des intérêt la France sera
capable de se déployer euh en masse avec des
ravitailleurs des avions de chasse et également
des avions de transport tactique en en soutien
pour pour finalement parer à toute à toute crise
potentielle pour conduire la métamorphose de la
base le colonel anlord Michel un nouveau défi dans
le parcours de celle qui était l'une des premières
femmes en France à devenir pilote de chasse sur
Mirage on peut voir que l'actualité internationale
est assez riche avec des bouleversements quel
effet cela a ou a eu sur votre base j'ai coutume
de dire que notamment grâce à cet avion qu'on voit
derrière nous le MRTT Phenix et bien la base
RN 125 est est au cœur de toute l'actualité
opérationnelle euh malheureusement ce qui se passe
en Israël aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé au Niger
et qui a encore des conséquences aujourd'hui
toutes ces missionsl et bien la base aéenne 1225
y participe rapatrier les ressortissants déployer
des forces en mission ravitailler des avions de
combat qui vont protéger les espaces aériens on y
participe est-ce que colonel pourraz revenir sur
cette mission justement de la dissuision quiass
sur votre base effectivement la la mission de
dissuasion nucléaire c'est la mission principale
de notre base aérienne dite à vocation nucléaire
c'est-à-dire que sur cette base aérienne sont
mis en œuvre des moyens aériens qui permettent
de garantir la crédibilité de la France en
terme de dissuasion nucléaire on sait depuis
malheureusement le déclenchement du conflit
en Ukraine que ce volet dissuasion est
particulièrement regardé d'un point de vue
politique de la part de nos compétiteurs et
que cela nous oblige à être très crédiible sur ce
volet donc cette base s'entraîne presque tous les
jours avec un haut niveau d'engagement à préparer
cette mission et et j'insiste un petit peu sur le
fait que nous sommes la composante visible de
la dissuasion nucléaire c'est-à-dire que c'est
c'est un mot qui pourrait paraître peu secret
mais on montre qu'on s'entraîne on montre qu'on
est préparé et qu'on a des moyens qui sont
extrêmement opérationnels pour réaliser cette
mission quatre fois par an l'Armée de l'Air
et de l'Espace réalise un raide nucléaire une
opération nocturne baptisée poker et qui n'a rien
un bluff en 2020 pour la première fois les forces
aériennes stratégiques décident de réaliser
cette opération en plein jour cette année-là
le ciel français désert le confinement a cloué
au sol toutes les activités aéronautiques après
21 ans de service le capitaine Pierre est l'un des
pilotes les plus expérimentés de son escadre c'est
une rare opération qui a lieu sur le territoire
national qui est une opération de dissuision
nucléaire où quatre fois par an on démontre
à d'éventuels agresseurs et à nos nos alliés
que nous sommes crédibles dans la dissuision
nucléaire et que si l'ordre nous était donné
de la mettre en œuvre on serait capable de le
faire alors nous on a on a un double rôle on a
déjà le rôle de plateforme de communication donc
le but ça sera de pouvoir faire une plateforme de
communication avec les états-majors et parce
que l'ordre arrive directement du président
ensuite dans le cas de la dissuision nucléaire
notre but est de pouvoir frapper là où on va
nous le demander quel que soit l'endroit et
ça peut être des endroits très lointains et
donc du coup l'avion ravita tailleur devient
essentiel pour la manœuvre des avions de chasse
[Applaudissements] c'est une opération où nous on
va jouer le fait que le Président de la République
nous engage donc on va recevoir un ordre de
de départ queon va mettre en œuvre le but est
décoller le plus rapidement possible au niveau
aviation de chasse on va y mettre énormément de
moyens parce qu'on va voir les avions qui vont
participer au raid avec nous et les avions qui
vont nous faire opposition pour nous empêcher
de passer depuis tout juste 60 ans les aviateurs
sont en alerte permanente au service de la
dissuision nucléaire la première fois c'était un
8 octobre 1964 la première prise d'alerte des
face donc moment où on est devenu autonome au
niveau politique et ben en fait les avions
ravitailleurs à cette époque là étaient déjà
présents ils ont participé à la première
prise d'alerte avec le binôme historique
qu'il est resté très longtemps mirage 4 et
c'est 135 fr à l'époque mais effectivement de
depuis 60 ans h 24 tout temps tout lieu on
assure une une permanence pour la dissuasion
[Musique]
nucléaire à l'abri des regards le capitaine Thomas
et ses hommes sont les angesgardiens discrets de
la base aérienne l'escadron de défense sol air
est capable d'intercepter toutes les menaces
venues du ciel le conflit en Ukraine a remis
en ses capacités des armées françaises alors
la dernière loi de programmation militaire prévoit
un investissement de 5 milliards d'euros dans ce
secteur on se retrouve face à des menaces
potentielles où il y a en face de nous une
aviation robuste qui nécessite potentiellement le
déploiement de de système de défense solaire le
mamba est à neutraliser à peu près tout types
de menac que ce soit missile drone avion gros
porteur avion de chasse ça sert à protéger les
forces déployées ça sert à protéger les grands
événements sur le territoire national ça sert
également à protéger les bases aériennes notamment
ici sur la base aérienne à vocation nucléaire
donc on a plusieurs types de mission sur le
territoire national comme en opération extérieure
à l'instar de la Roumanie où on est actuellement
déployé pour protéger le flan est des pays de
l'OTAN à quelques pas de là le capitaine Thomas
veut nous montrer une arme d'un tout autre genre
c'est l'autre enseignement de la guerre en Ukraine
la menace drone est en train de changer l'art de
la guerre ok on a en tracking une de là on essaie
de reprendre le drone et il vole beaucoup plus
lentement on le met en tracking en tracking ça
veut dire la caméra le suit sans qu'on ait besoin
de bouger manuellement c'est dire c'est la caméra
par des les capteurs avec les capteurs en fait il
va il va suivre le drone à la trace vas-y double C
ouais voilà c'est bon ok en gros touche à rien
là s lâche le joystick la caméra elle suit le
drone la caméra va nous proposer plusieurs PL qui
pour potentiellement être un drone c'est-à-dire
ils vont tout ce qui a des hélices tout ce qui
tourner tout ce qui va voler donc des fois ils
peuvent nous proposer des oiseaux c'est pour
ça que l'opérateur il est important parce que
c'est lui qui va décider si c'est un drone ou pas
après suite à ça on est en capacité de pouvoir
les détecter et les intercepter en fonction
des différents systèmes et là notamment avec
le système basal nous on va vraiment identifier la
menace et rendre compte pour que l'officier prenne
la décision là c'est le l'opérateur ça va être
une question de rapidité et de de clairvaillance
dans la prise de décision pour rendre compte
directement à l'officier de supervision 200
m ok j'ai un numéro de série il se dirige vers le
point à défendre donc on est autorisé à ok je l'ai
en tracking lancer la procédure de brouillage bien
reçu système basalt c'est un ensemble de systèmes
qui permet de connecter différents senseurs pour
détecter les menaces la principale menace actuelle
qui est la menace mini drone donc vous avez pour
cela plusieurs senseurs du radar de laagoniométrie
qui va permettre de faire de l'écoute de fréquence
une caméra qui peut faire une acquisition visuelle
et également le dispositifs infodrone qui permet
de détecter les drones qui sont équipés des puces
infodrone alors une fois que le drone a été
détecté identifié et classifié on peut lancer
une procédure de brouillage tout va dépendre des
consignes opérationnelles qui nous sont données
si ce drone est à l'extérieur de la zit donc de
la Zone Interdite il n'y aura pas de procédure
de brouillage néanmoins s'il pénètre la zone
interdite et qu'il se dirige vers le point à
défendre là nous serons en mesure de le brouiller
s'il n'est pas autorisé et pour moi il en altitude
il est au sol est posé l'intérêt de l'armée de
l'air c'est d'agréger tous les acteurs inter
ministériel et interarmé et pouvoir coordonner
l'ensemble de l'emploi des moyens de lutte
[Rires] antidrone
avertisseur sonore prévient
un message autorisé détecé
position de l'antenne positionte I et
information on a le modèle D phant 4
idention
par P intertioné l anone est une
permanente à l'innovation alors la
be aérienne veutêtre en première ligne
dans la recherche de nouvell solution
matin les équipes de protection de la be
expériment un nouveau système de [Musique]
détectional d'autres types DRC maison
aujourd'hui on a que la détection mais ils ont
aussi une capacité de brouillage qui sera testé
ultérieurement de ce qu' nous ont dit aujourd'hui
il peuvent même brouiller précisément un drone
plutôt qu'envoyer un cône il focalise sur le
drone parce qu'il capte la fréquence du drone
il brouille que cette fréquence ok ramène
le drone et début du boucl sur 100 m c'est
parti il y a des missions qui n'attendent
pas et d'autres dont l'attente fait partie
de la mission 24h/ 24 des aviateurs
veillent sur l'espace aérien [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [Musique] français le DAL le
feu la trappe est fermée les sondes V obstruer pas
d' SF le radome la pointe le radome en bon état
la perche de ravitaillement les sondes dans obstru
le feu le dalle le LM en sécu
déverrouillé hors connexion
vont pas de PO dur pas de fuite pas de point
dur pas de fuite la dérive on est bien en sécu
il y a pas de fuite antenne en bon état rien
dans le moteur rien dans la poubelle et enau
fix SCU cross en V robinet ouvert il est
en sécu et il est plein les trappes sont
fermées la trappette additionnelle la BBM rien
dans l'entrée derrière bien la sonde et rien
dans le piège à gauche limite [Applaudissements]
[Musique] [Applaudissements] [Musique] merci on
a des appareils qui sont prêts au au quatre
coins de la France pour faire à la fois une
mission de police de ciel on va venir contrôler
des avions qui peuvent bah être en infraction
ou porter assistance à des avions en panne ou
perdu mauvaise météo et choses comme ça on est
deux pilotes un pilote d'alerte l'autre qui est
en soutien et qui va a passé d'alerte quand le
premier sera déclenché et donc pendant ce temps-là
bah lui il peut effectivement faire du sport ou
s'occuper à côté tout en restant bah disponible on
est dans une zone normalement qui est fermée où on
vit entre nous pendant une semaine comme ça dès
que le klaxon retentit normalement tout le monde
l'entend et et tout le monde se met BR de combat
d'accord c'est c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
fréquent alors des alertes réel il y en a il y en
a beaucoup pas quotidiennement mais mais quasiment
mais qui peuvent être du simple avion de ligne
en panne radio qui répond plus pendant X minutes
ou le petit avion de tourisme qui a décollé pour
faire campagne et qui se retrouve bloqué audessus
d'une couche de nuage qui n'arrive pas à rentrer
après on avait suivi il y a quelques quelques mois
l'appareil qui avait été intercepté en train de
larguer des paquets de de drogue voilà ça c'est
plus exceptionnel quand même heureusement donc
la majorité des cas c'est des choses plutôt de
l'assistance
[Musique]
la fin de la métamorphose de la base confirme la
place primordiale qu'elle occupe dans l'histoire
de l'aéronautique Istre est depuis toujours
une terre d'aviation ici le monde se divise
en deux catégories ceux qui volent et
ceux qui rêvent de [Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voler [Musique]